sur france 2 aura lieu la 35e édition
des victoires de la musique
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que l'événement peine à rassembler les
foules l'audience baisse d'année en
année 2 millions de téléspectateurs l'an
dernier versus 2,8 millions en 2018
il faut dire que les artistes ne se
bousculent pas non plus pour participer
à la cérémonie qui est de plus en plus
mauvaise presse dans le milieu ça n'a
aucun intérêt pour moi ce sont 300
personnes qui votent entre elles il y a
une forme de lobbying là dedans que je
trouve un peu crétin
j'ai quitté l'école à 14 ans ce n'est
pas pour être notée par des gens dont je
me passe le reproche principal fait à la
cérémonie elle n'est pas assez ouverte
sur le vrai public et favoriserait
beaucoup trop lente reçoit parisien
l'exemple le plus parlant est le système
de vote bien sur un système de vote
fermés ou un collège de 600
professionnels et liste des lauréats
pour cette 35e édition les victoires de
la musique ont choisi comme président
d'honneur florent pagny un choix
surprenant quand on sait que l'ex-coach
de the voice semblait ne pas être en
phase avec la cérémonie voici ce qu'il
déclarait en 2014
les victoires sans moi c'est un truc du
métier je vis de la musique mais je
n'appartiens pas à ce milieu je ne suis
pas le genre d'artiste qui les fait
rêver a priori florent pagny a changé
d'avis concernant la cérémonie de france
la liberté de pensée mais ça n'est pas
le cas de beaucoup d'artistes comme
mylène farmer par exemple alors selon
vous pourquoi certains chanteurs
boycottent les victoires de la musique
[Musique]
résumé on reproche à la cérémonie sera
un événement parisien à paraître garde
le trou de balle alors vous vous étiez
vous aviez été en charge forcément un
peu indirectement de cette cérémonie
kate vous en pensez puisque les banques
c'est une chance d'aboutir
d'abord c'est une série très très longue
donc c'est assez rentable de regarder
gifle ont ensuite on s'ennuie et surtout
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment un entre
soi c'est à dire que normalement le
service public ce qui doit mettre en
avant c'est les meilleures ventes de
disques tout au long de l'année et faire
voter laisser malka ça n'est pas le cas
effectivement c'est fermé alors l'âme
annoncé 600 votants
à l'époque c'était quelques milliers de
votants c'est assez bizarre ce sont 1
des votes de professionnels vous
retrouver de temps en temps des les
promos vous retrouvez vous retrouver de
temps en temps des artistes qui viennent
mais qui font leur promo du moment
les disques personne ne connaît sur
lequel personne n'a dansé et de temps en
temps je voulais même pas envie
d'acheter
c'est très compliqué alors restez quelle
année où il y avait une chanteuse qui a
fait un prêt on la connaissait mais pas
du tout normal on est tous les genres ah
oui d'accord et tous les tous les ans et
puis vous donner un exemple vous avez
pascal obispo qui est un gros vendeur de
disques
je crois qu'il a été il a dû être nommé
au moins vingt fois où 24 fois et il n'a
jamais eu une récompense
est ce que c'est normal que des artistes
comme pascal obispo ne soit pas mieux
représenté dans une victoire de la
musique du service public les gars on va
sur les audiences
a priori ça ne marchera pas non ça
serait très bas comme valentin va dire à
sa mère vient chéri on va regarder ben
oui j'aimerais qu'on chante oui ou non
mais moi je veux dire par rapport aux
artistes qui boudaient les victoires de
la musique je pense qu'en fait il faut
trouver une autre manière de voter pour
eux parce que c'est leur public en fait
c'est eux qui reçoivent des messages
et c'est pas je pense pas que tout le
monde puisse comprendre les messages
cachés de certains artistes dans ces
professionnels mais plus beau mais là il
ya un prix du public comme c'était
attendu
excusez moi mais cette année ils ont
justement entendu ça la critique parce
qu'il ya 200 non professionnels qui sera
ajouté aux six ans
il va passer